it doesn't feel quite real to say this
but mission accomplished I did it I
actually made it through my extraction
is currently on the route and once
they're here I'll be heading back to the
SCP Foundation it doesn't feel like a
hundred days since this all started if
anything it feels like a lot longer but
it's done now the mission is finally
over and now the real work begins I'll
be taken in for debriefing when I arrive
so I better get my story straight before
the transport gets here here's how I
survived 100 days infiltrating the chaos
Insurgency it started with a message a
direct request passed down straight to
me from the o5 council themselves I was
shocked initially to receive any
communication from them the council were
hardly Hands-On bosses preferring to
coordinate the foundation from a station
far far above mine I was part of a
mobile task force used to being out in
the field so when I got the message
saying the council wanted to talk to me
I wasn't quite sure what to make of it I
went through various stages of reaction
in my head first being honored that they
had singled out then that turned to
worry had I done something wrong or was
this some kind of dismissal from the
foundation was it a performance review
when it finally came time for me to
stand before the o5 council the last
thing I was expecting to hear was that
they had selected me specifically for a
dangerous undercover assignment of
course I'd heard of the chaos Insurgency
before although I was yet to actually
encounter them in the field the mtfs
were all instructed to keep up to date
on who the foundation's enemies were as
a group of Interest it wasn't hard to
see why they were such a threat a
heavily armed clandestine organization
with goals of weaponizing scps and
achieving world domination they sounded
like lunatics but dangerous lunatics all
the same this was the first step in my
mission know your enemy I was instructed
to familiarize myself with the chaos
Insurgency to understand them inside and
out while the MTF agent in me wanted to
just get boots on the ground and start
the real work this operation needed a
different approach and so so I hit the
books or to put it more accurately I
began scouring the SCP foundation's
database for any and all Intel on the
Insurgency all I could do was sit and
raid within 48 Hours of being given my
assignment I felt like I knew everything
about the chaos Insurgency back to front
sideways upside down and pretty much any
and every way possible so imagine how
disheartened I felt when I reported my
research to the o5 council only to be
told that I hadn't done enough hardly
the best feeling I won't deny it stung
to hear that my day of research was an
adequate prep for my assignment but the
council did have an important point this
was a covert Deep Cover infiltration
into one of the most dangerous groups
that opposed the foundation purely
memorizing all manner of facts and
figures about the Insurgency learning of
all their tactical capabilities reading
up on the various rumors about how they
were founded all that was just knowledge
if I wanted to pass myself off as a part
of the chaos Insurgency and avoid
detection knowing wasn't enough I had to
think like one of them the timeline of
the mission began to accelerate rapidly
I would have to train myself to believe
the insurgency's core beliefs as I went
along events weren't going to wait for
me to be ready the council informed me
that they were aware of a double agent
working for the chaos Insurgency from
within the SCP Foundation itself
obviously I had heard rumors that there
were operatives embedded within the
ranks of the foundation but what was
more surprising was that the o5 council
seemed to already know who these agents
were I'd always assumed that these
insurgents kept their identities a
secret so hearing that a particular
researcher Dr Parsons was a known chaos
Insurgency conspirator and still had a
job at the foundation was both startling
and worrying but he provided me a way in
and I assume that's why the o5 council
allowed the insurgencies double agents
to remain as quote undetected as they
thought they were it meant they could be
used as tools for the foundation benefit
to get at the Insurgency that they were
double agents after all Dr Parsons was
due to be at the same Foundation site I
was stationed at for only a few days the
upside of working directly on the orders
of the council meant that they had the
administrative reach to uphold all the
necessary strings to get this
duplicitous double agent in the right
place for me to intercept him but not
for long the window of opportunity was
only a small one I had a short time to
get close enough to Parsons and get him
to put me in contact with his friends at
the chaos Insurgency of course I had to
be tactful about it if I came on too
strong there was a strong chance the
double agent would easily detect that
something was off and that his cover had
been blown So the plan was simple struck
up a conversation with the spy in a way
that wouldn't arouse suspicion and would
compel him to assist my joining the
chaos Insurgency actually simple might
not have been the right word the day of
my confrontation with Parsons I was
uncontrollably nervous I could feel
myself shaking and silently hoped that
it wasn't noticeable to anyone looking
at me the mess hall was decided as the
best place I could drum up some kind of
conversation with him as I picked up my
food tray I spotted the doctor taking a
seat in the far Corner cautiously I
approached and asked if I could join him
in the back of my head I kept reminding
myself I had to play it casual if I went
in immediately with claiming I felt the
foundation should be run differently
then Parsons would smell the deception
and the whole mission would come apart
so instead I started small we dreamed up
a conversation about the quality of the
food the foundation catering team had
given us or rather the lack of quality
then we chatted about containment
procedures and various anomalies that we
had each encountered in our different
jobs lunch was wrapping up we both
finished our food and I knew my window
was about to close and so I threw into
conversation you know you ever get sick
of the way they do things the entire
next day I was on edge worried that I've
thrown my assignment and alerted Parsons
that the foundation was aware of his
ties to the Insurgency I didn't leave
the task force Barracks confining myself
to my quarters the vile left there was
always a slim chance of running into Dr
Parsons or that the council would call
me in to reprimand how I handled the
first contact to my surprise my paranoid
thoughts were broken by a direct message
from Parsons he mentioned being
intrigued by some of our conversation
the previous day and being disappointed
I hadn't been in the mess hall this
lunch time to continue discussing
certain aspects it felt weirdly nice
being friendly only to then remember the
man was a double agent for the chaos
Insurgency his message went on to
suggest we should meet in private in his
office and that's when the tension
really hit me either he wanted me dead
with no Witnesses or he had bought my
line about disagreeing with the
foundation's methods I arrived at
Parsons office at the agreed time only
to be welcomed one by the doctor it was
instantly disarming and intentionally so
I tried not to fall for it just in case
he knew what I was really up to but at
the same time I couldn't let it show Dr
Parsons seemed to pick up our discussion
from the other day immediately talking
about how the SCP Foundation would be
better off putting anomalies to use
rather than keeping them contained I was
surprised how Brazen he was being but
then again the council knew he was a
mole maybe they had bugged his office
and he hadn't realized nodding along
pretending to agree with what the doctor
was saying the conversation quickly
progressed I told Parsons I felt the
same and it was frustrating to me as an
MTF agent seeing so many co-workers die
in containment breaches against scps
that was the moment he mentioned he had
some friends I should meet the following
night they came for me while I slept in
the barracks I had no idea who had
drugged me although I suspected it was
Dr Parson he wasn't there when I woke up
though in fact I couldn't really tell
who it was at first the combination of
the bag over my face and my head still
reeling from whatever had knocked me out
saw to that wherever I was I didn't get
to see it there were figures near me at
least two not much I could make out
especially when the interrogation
started they were chaos Insurgency the
line of questioning told me that between
punches and tasting their questions
range from what I was really up to to
whether the foundation had sent me to
infiltrate their organization they'd
anticipated the council would use their
own tactics against them but every time
no matter how much pain they inflicted I
denied it I wasn't a mole I told them
over and over again I believed what they
believed after over a week of torture
the bag came off and I was greeted by
the side of my captors in chaos
Insurgency tactical gear they informed
me that I had passed the initial phase
of their recruitment process and after
offering so much that should have come
as a relief my mission to infiltrate
them was progressing but their
interrogation had left me exhausted and
in intense pain the pair of insurgents
made it very clear that I wasn't one of
them though not yet in order to fully
join their ranks they wanted to send me
on an operation with one of their armed
detachments if I complied with orders
and made a deliberate act against the
SCP Foundation that would tell them that
I was ready to become part of the chaos
Insurgency if I refused or the mission
was deemed to be a failure it would mean
an on-the-spot execution hiding my
reluctance knowing I wouldn't be able to
forewarn the foundation I agreed I spent
the next several days with a new group
of Insurgency operatives none of them
gave me their names nor any actionable
intel I could pass on to the council I
just had to refer to them by their
various gamma and beta class numbers
their ranks within the chaos Insurgency
the mission was an extraction as part of
their efforts to utilize anomalies the
Insurgency would often launch violent
raids on the foundation to capture scps
their target this time was scp-2800
cactus man he was mostly harmless save
for his spines but the group's leaders
dealt a command wanted to force scp-2800
to join their ranks I had to treat it
like any other operation with my ntf
trying to force myself to forget that I
was on the wrong side as we broke into
the site containing scp-2800 he didn't
want to leave but I hope that the
foundation would eventually launch a
counter mission to rescue him all that
mattered for now was making the
Insurgency see that I could be helpful
and useful to them sure enough the
foundation did recover scp-2800 and by
the time they did the chaos Insurgency
had already welcomed me into their ranks
I'd proven myself and that I shared
their beliefs in utilizing the anomalies
to realize their goals during the
mission I had made it a point of showing
my EXP variants and skills as an MTF
operative hoping that would impress them
it seemed to have done the trick as I
was made a member of beta class still
under the command of gamma and Delta
command above them but it was a start at
least not as low in the chain as the
alpha class were they were the
Insurgency recruits with no experience
dealing with anomalies and who only
joined to escape their miserable lives
Delta command considered Alpha class
Expendable as if they were little more
than Canon fodder I couldn't help but
feel bad for them especially when I
realized that the foundation treated
their d-class exactly the same even the
mtfs were mostly foot soldiers to them
now established within the insurgency's
ranks I spent the next two weeks finding
out everything I could about their
operations and Reporting back to the o5
council through a secure encrypted
Channel part of my infiltration mission
was to see if I could locate the engine
a mysterious anomalous artifact that had
apparently influenced the earliest
members of Now Delta command to form in
the chaos Insurgency in the first place
there was no sign of the engine anywhere
in the compound I was stationed at then
again its location was likely a closely
guarded secret I did however encounter
one of the anomalies within the
insurgency's possession it was
scp-1316 what appeared to be an ordinary
and harmless kitten named Lucy but an
actuality scp-1316 was an intelligent
and sophisticated listening device used
to spy on the foundation and report back
to the Insurgency I made sure to warn
the council the moment I found out
letting them know it wasn't just double
agents being used to report on
Foundation activity just as things were
starting to form a regular pattern
things seemed to start going South a few
of my fellow insurgents seem to mention
things in conversation that made me
start to feel paranoid they weren't
directly referencing me but they talked
openly about what they do if they found
out the foundation had tried to spy on
the Insurgency and none of it was
Pleasant I spent the rest of the day
racked with worry there was no way they
could have known I was communicating
with the o5 council or that the only
reason I was there had been to gather
intelligence on the chaos Insurgency it
could have just been what people talked
about here although I couldn't shake my
concern that maybe my cover had been
blown that this was their subtle way of
telling me that chaos Insurgency was on
to me the worrying left me no choice and
I raised my concerns with the council
the first chance I got unfortunately the
response I received the following day
did little to subdue my worries the o5
council contacted me reminding me of the
importance of my mission I was to
infiltrate and report back to them find
the engine or at least its location it
was an extraction planned arriving in
secrets in a month's time that was my
time limit and a warning came with it if
you cannot complete this assignment then
don't bother returning to the foundation
the council told me if you are
unsuccessful in carrying out your
objectives it will be taken as an act of
sedition we will consider you an active
member of the chaos Insurgency and thus
a threat to the foundation I was Furious
not to mention scared out of my mind the
council was willing to turn their backs
on me if I couldn't deliver and if the
Insurgency found out they had a mole in
their ranks then it sounded like they
were ready to kill me on the spot the
Insurgency were gearing up for another
mission this time a more aggressive
attack on the foundation as opposed to
the stealthier extraction that I'd
previously been on surprisingly that put
me more at ease sure it'd be dangerous
but this was what I was good at in the
field intensely combating anomalies I
could use this as an opportunity to
regain some footing remind the chaos
Insurgency what made me useful to them
or so I thought the mission was to
capture
scp-682 and fit it with a piece of
technology the Insurgency had tested on
scp-2394 a form of Sapient Frog their
plan was that the device would enable
them to control the hard to destroy
reptile meaning the Insurgency would
have an Unstoppable adaptable killing
machine in their Arsenal the attack on
the foundation site was a bloodbath mtfs
beset the insurgents on all sides and as
for 682 while it wasn't exactly known
for coming quietly without putting up a
fight returning from the field after
only a few days I was confronted by a
higher up a member of gamma class that
oversaw the insurgency's operations he
told me that there had been numerous
reports from other operatives that they
hadn't seen me killing or even injuring
Foundation Personnel during the failed
extraction of 682 it was true I was
still loyal to the foundation after all
the people working there were still my
co-workers even if I was pretending to
be an Insurgent I deliberately missed
shots still using my weapon in the
firefights with mtfs but without causing
them harm I'd hope nobody in the
Insurgency would notice but it seemed
they had
I brushed off the accusation made some
excuse about needing to go for an eye
exam and contact lenses but under the
surface were Relentless shutters of
panic in hindsight the gamma officer had
told me this so the Insurgency could see
how I reacted but at the time I didn't
realize and that played right into their
hand the next day I was caught while
going to send an urgent SOS message to
the o5 council before I could reach the
place I stashed my encrypted com device
a group of Cass Insurgency beta class
operatives rushed me I was bagged again
pulled away kicking and screaming and
unable to call for help over the next
few days it was like I'd been sent back
in time to the start of my infiltration
as the Insurgency tortured me again I
refused to give in despite how much I
wanted to just make the pain stop but
even then it didn't matter their
knowledge of the foundation was greater
than I realized and the insurgents were
easily able to crack the encryption of
my communit with that broken they had
access to all the messages I'd been
sending to the 5 Council and realizing
who had sent me made them change their
interrogation methods the insurgents
revealed something I hadn't heard before
something the council had apparently
kept a secret the gas Insurgency had
once been a part of the SCP Foundation I
refused to believe it at first but with
all I'd seen as an MTF agent even my
undercover Mission it started to make
sense and off the Record Black Ops unit
working for the o5 council to circumvent
the Ethics Committee they'd grown
disillusioned with how the foundation
handled its anomalies and broken away to
form the chaos Insurgency when I
accepted that to be true the insurgents
brought me to what I'd been sent for
they took me to the engine now I'm
awaiting my extraction transport after
showing me the device that caused their
earliest Founders to Splinter off from
the foundation the Cass Insurgency took
me several miles from their compound to
the coordinates the o5 council had told
me to be at the foundation think they're
getting their agent back and with me
plenty of intel on their enemies but the
engine showed me the truth showed me the
lies and fallacies of the foundation and
especially the o5 council they think
they're getting back their agent but I
serve the chaos Insurgency now now go
check out SCP chaos Insurgency explained
and I survived 100 days hiding from the
SCP Foundation here's what happened for
more mind-blowing Centennial challenges